نعم ، إنها طائرة كبيرة جدًا
يمكنك رؤيتها ويمكنك أن ترى أين تنقسم
في المنتصف الآن لحسن الحظ ،
لا يوجد أي منازل أو أي شيء
بالقرب من هذا ، فهذه هي الأخبار السارة التي
تعرف أنها تبدو وكأنها تريد بالتأكيد
لضرب أي شخص أه ينزل مثل أي منزل
أو أي نوع من السيارات ويبدو
أن هناك طريقًا ترابيًا قديمًا
أحاول الحصول على عنوان um لذلك
ولكن نعم عندما تقوم بتكبير الصورة
يبدو وكأنها  قد تكون
طائرة تجارية طائرة كبيرة تمامًا
كما تعلمون أنها ليست طائرة
سيسنا أو مقاتلة أصغر تعمل
بشكل عادل ، في مقابل محاولة
إخماد النيران على هذه
الطائرة الكبيرة ومرة أخرى أعرف أن طيارتي كا
يتحدث إلى الهواء  التحكم في حركة المرور
وطائرات الهليكوبتر الأخرى هنا حيث سأحاول
الحصول على مزيد من المعلومات منه ،
ولكن بمجرد النظر إلى الطائرة
والتحدث عن ما يصل إلى 20 شخصًا
على متنها ، وهذا بالتأكيد
ليس واردًا على
الإطلاق.  الناس على متن تلك الطائرة
لأنها طائرة أكبر ومرة أخرى تع
مون للأسف أنه عندما يكون هناك تح
م طائرة إذا كان بإمكانهم الهبوط في حقل مث
هذا في الواقع ، فإن طيارتي ديف ألين ين
ر باستمرار إلى الخارج إذا واجهنا عط
في المحرك أو ركضنا  في
نوع من المواقف ، لديه دائمًا مكان
أو مكان يمكنه الهبوط فيه في منتصف الطريق ، وكان
الطيارون مدربون على القيام بذلك أه
للتأكد من أنهم إذا
واجهوا مشكلة يمكنهم الهبوط لأن
الأفضل